( intro music )
( applause )
- Pam: Welcome.
- Marcus: Thank you.
Do you mind if we talk a
little bit about your
early years,
your early biography of...
You were adopted when
you were three years old
you and your sister.
After your mother
had fallen ill.
In fact, many, many people
in Ethiopia
had fallen ill, tuberculosis?
Yeah.
Both my mom, my sister,
myself we had it, and,
you know, we lived out
in the countryside
and it was really
my mom and my sister
that walked into
a big hospital.
Marcus: My mom passed away,
my sister and I,
we survived.
So, talking about Sweden
and talking about your,
your adopted parents.
Ann-Marie is your
mother's name, and...
she wasn't much of a cook,
was she?
My mom was a horrible cook.
Nice woman.
- ( audience laughter )
- Marcus: Horrible cook!
Her mother was a
fantastic cook.
So, what about your
grandmother's roast chicken?
- Can we talk about that?
- Yeah!
I mean, Helga... You know,
the funny thing with...
The cooks that I know,
the cooks that I sort of admire
they all came out of poverty.
When I think about, but you
know, they lived a rich life.
When I think about
the cooks that mattered
the most in my life,
I think about a lady like
Leah Chase, down in New Orleans
that sort of had the first
integrated restaurant
in this country.
Owned her own business
since the 40s in America.
And, my grandmother, you know,
they were born into poverty
but they knew how to cook.
And...
So they ate well but maybe,
you know,
didn't have, what we think,
as a lot of money.
And, my grandmother's cooking,
although when she passed away
she was a middle class
Swedish woman that did,
you know,
that did very well.
But her cooking came
out of poverty.
That never changed.
Her DNA on roasting chicken
putting the vegetable
underneath
letting the chicken fat drip in.
The next day have
a chicken soup
and maybe the third day
having chicken dumpling.
- You know, so, the way she--
- She really stretched
that bird.
Yeah, stretched that bird
and always had the broth on
in the back.
You know,
she was smart, smart lady.
she had also child labor.
- She had us three...
- ( audience laughter )
...running up and down,
taking care of the pantry
and making like,
there was always--
When you entered her house,
you had to work.
There was always
something going on.
Now, thinking about
that chicken, too
what I thought was really
interesting was that
your grandmother
instinctively knew something
about the temperature that
that chicken needed to be
in the same way that
chefs who are cooking
a 27 dollar chicken today,
do the same thing
but they do it in
a different way.
Can you talk about
that a little bit?
You know,
that cooking is...
It's like anything you do a lot
it's just instinct, right?
It's almost like Jazz musicians,
you know it.
Some people come from it
from a school,
some people were
just born with it.
But when you have that concert
or when you're cooking
it doesn't really matter,
we're here now.
And either you
learn those muscles
or you don't.
My mom had this
fancy electric oven,
my grandmother never
trusted that oven, so...
My grandmother,
she had
an oven that we'd have to
feed with wood all the time.
So, just understanding
how an oven worked,
things like that
a cooking school's not
going to teach you that.
- Pam: Yeah.
- Cooking school is also not
going to teach how you taste
something and, you know.
She used to taste the sauce
by pouring it straight
into her hand
and tasting it like this.
- Right.
- You know.
There was, you know...
So stuff like that,
you know, you have to be a
real craftsmen to understand.
So,
at Aquavit, how excited
were you when they said,
"Yeah, come and...
come and work here."
No, it's very exciting.
Aquavit has always been,
sort of the,
the only Scandinavian restaurant
outside Scandinavia.
Marcus: The person that owned
Aquavit at the time,
he came back after
a couple of months,
"I'm looking for a chef."
And he said, "I know who is
going to be the new chef."
I'm like, "Who is it?"
"You're going to
be the new chef."
And I was like,
"Well, let me think about this."
Because it made me nervous.
I didn't wanna be...
Aquavit is a very famous
restaurant in Scandinavia.
I didn't wanna be the
guy to close it.
( audience laughter )
I'm like... Isn't that because
I was just being paranoid
I'm like,
"No, I don't want all that."
But I also knew that
timing of stuff
doesn't always work.
You know, I wrote to
get to three-star
Michelin restaurants 30 times
before I got in.
That didn't fit with my timing.
- ( audience laughter )
- So, you know,
there were 30,
there was 29 no's,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- So, I also knew the opposite
of that timing is just not
going to be presented to you
and I think it even helped me
being black, in that case.
Because I knew how
rare we get the shots.
So, you better take it.
Right, you better do
the most out of it.
Well, and you definitely made
that opportunity work for you
because I think
by the time you were
literally, just less than a
year later when you were 24,
a little food writer named
Ruth Reichl in the
New York Times
reviewed your meal.
- Yeah.
- And something happened.
We got three stars from
New York Times and, you know--
You're the youngest...
He is the youngest chef
to ever receive a three-star
review from the New York Times.
I mean, come on!
( applause )
But, what I like about
that more than anything is
that we really had no clue
that she was in the building.
Any of those times.
And when I say like,
"We had no clue,
we had no clue."
Did she wear a
disguise or something?
It wouldn't matter to us,
because we didn't know.
We were so disorganized.
- ( audience laughter )
- We were just working.
It could have said
" New York Times "
on her forehead
we wouldn't have known.
So, what happened
after Aquavit?
What was your next
big adventure?
You know, I remember the
weekend before 9/11,
I did,
I was cooking at The Towers.
I was cooking there, down there,
and the following weekend
the weekend of 9/11,
I was in Australia.
And I just remember,
a guy waking me up, like,
knocked on my door,
"You gotta put on the TV".
And I saw this stuff
that happened
and I knew a lot of those cooks,
I knew a lot of those servers,
I knew a lot of...
I knew chefs.
At The Tower? The restaurant
at the top. Right.
And it was one of those times
when you start thinking about,
"Okay. What am I doing?"
Like, whether, is
this going to be...
Is this going to be my life
to cook for the richest
people in the world
for the rest, fill at least
80 seats every night?
And I started to think about,
you know, what can a chef do,
what is my other purposes.
And, my call was
that experience,
right, the post-that.
Yeah.
And, I decided to,
"You know what,
let me,
let me move to Harlem.
Let me move somewhere else."
So, I'm like, "What if...
You know, what if I can open
a small restaurant here that
puts the community...
Becomes a waterhole
for the community.
That is of and
similar to Sylvia's
in the place of
creating jobs.
But just done a
little bit different."
And that was really when
the whole idea of Red Rooster,
for me,
started to become real.
Marcus: And then by 2010,
we opened Red Rooster.
And, how is it
doing these days?
We have been very fortunate,
you know.
( knocks on wood )
- Very fortunate.
- Yeah.
Marcus: We're really blessed
by the community
and we're really blessed by...
But, you know,
it's not about--
I never measured a restaurant,
and it's easy to say when
you're busy all the time,
but I don't measure it by
how busy it is.
I measure it by
the goals and
the reason why I put
it in there.
What is--
What was the purpose?
What is the core purpose?
The purpose was to
really create something to
inspire and aspire, right?
The purpose was to
create jobs of the trade
that I've been lucky enough
to be a part of.
The purpose was
to also create
another, so young,
particularly,
people of color can say
"Hey, I can own a business.
Hey, I can become a chef.
Hey, I can become a bartender."
Whatever your goal is.
But it's a field here
and here is an--
It represents an opportunity.
This trade that lot of people
of color really started in
and served in, but the minute
it became a profession
didn't fit into anymore,
can really take back
its authorship.
That's the intent.
And that takes time.
And, thank you so much for
coming and being with us.
- Marcus, thank you.
- Well done.
You did a great job.
- You did.
- ( applause )